in December of 2005 while attempting to
capitalize on the zombie craze that had
gripped the United States and most of
the world Marvel produced a 5 issue
limited series depicting popular Marvel
characters as zombies and the chaos that
would ensue as a result of their
transformation what's going on guys this
is Rob and today we're going to be
talking about Marvel Zombies
just noggin laughing ah no no your
father's both of us we know it's cool
all right you know yeah that's the
spirit there you go you guys walk up
come on tour come on hit her on the head
knock her out it's great what I mean yes
dude look at those melons man come on
show huh she's the hottest girl in
school there you go you go there you go
come on man using those rusted steel
baby so the zombie craze is really kind
of one of these funny things that no one
can really cite the origin to but
everybody knows how big it is you know
there really isn't a time at which we
could point our finger to and say this
is when zombies became popular it was
just one of those things that kind of
progressed on its own as time went by I
guess if we had to pick a particular
date we could probably go back and say
that it was when George Romero wrote and
directed the night of Living Dead which
was the 1960s version I think I'm not I
don't number the exact date of the film
but at this point it was really kind of
a total change a total 180 from the way
we had previously seen zombies depicted
in popular media in pop culture
zombies prior to the Night of the Living
Dead film or usually depicted as the
result of voodoo rituals that is to say
that a person was kind of taken in by a
voodoo priest or a voodoo priestess and
they were put under a spell of sorts
that kind of put them in a comatose or
zombified state this was the the kind of
turning point this was the one different
thing and they knotted living-dead it
changed everything and from there it
really just kind of spun out into a
multi-billion dollar industry of its own
we've seen zombies depicted in a
multitude of different ways and we've
seen a multitude of sequels we've seen
Dawn of the Dead and Day of the Dead
land of the dead the Max Brooks novel
World War Z which to this day I still
say is one of the greatest zombie
stories ever told there is a great big
huge culture that revolves around
zombies and so it makes sense that
somewhere along the line Marvel would
kind of dip their toe in the water and
see what they could do with regards to
zombies now the way that Marvel did
zombies was really really interesting
that in and of itself was kind of a
break away from tradition when you go
and look at various forms of zombies or
the different incarnations of zombies
what you see are these non-thinking
flesh-eating machines that's basically
all they do the zombies are incapable of
rational thought they're incapable of
doing anything other than walking around
consuming flesh and then going and
consuming more flesh that's all they do
that's all they want to do is all
they're all they're capable of doing
with Marvel Zombies the
Marvel characters for the most part
retain all their personality they're
capable of thought they're capable of
speaking they have arguments among each
other and they have disagreements and
they agree and they team up and
different things like that the only
difference here is that they are now
driven to consume flesh so when the
five-issue limited series starts off it
really starts off with magneto as the
last man standing and it takes place in
an alternate Marvel reality it doesn't
take place in our earth-616 reality I
think it's called the earth 21:49
reality but I'm not going to swear to
that but at this point we don't know
what caused the zombie outbreak in this
reality all we know is that at some
point along the line some unknown
superhero showed up in the and this is
this alternate earth 2149 universe and
started turning people into zombies now
in the backstories we learned that this
person was actually ash Williams and for
those of you guys who don't know ash
Williams is the main main star the main
protagonist and the Evil Dead series and
the Evil Dead series or the army of
darkness as it was at this point in time
was a series that was wildly popular
among fans and still remains to this day
is really it's a bad film in terms of
its the film itself but it is one that
is quotable by anyone who loves it
because it's a cult classic at this
point Dynamite Entertainment which was
and still is a comic book publishing
company that publishes comics based on
popular tales popular characters like
Robocop and terminator at this point
they were publishing limited issues on
the army of Darkness and so Dynamite
Entertainment and Marvel got together
and they created a backstory and the
backstory was that at some point along
the line ash Williams was fighting the
Deadites and he was essentially killed
and as a result he was transported to
this alternate alternate Marvel
dimension where he tried to warn the
Avengers which is the time consisted of
Hawkeye Colonel America who was the
alternate version of Captain America in
this timeline Iron Man spider-man Luke
Cage Wolverine giant man he had tried to
warn them
the impending danger of the Deadites who
were going to invade the earth and
offend essentially turn everybody into
zombies but they of course ignored him
his story sounded preposterous as time
progresses the century who is the first
superhero to be converted into a zombie
begins infecting virtually everybody
else and and as a result the entire
planet just kind of Spurs out of control
into a zombie apocalypse now for the
most part this really kind of goes back
and re-edit the history of Marvel Comics
not in the sense that everybody gets new
origin stories but with as being an
alternate dimension Marvel kind of had a
blank slate and so this story really
kind of takes place around the time that
the Fantastic Four came into contact
with Silver Surfer and Galactus now the
Silver Surfer shows up as a herald to
announce the coming of Galactus and he
is almost immediately consumed by the
Marvel Zombies and of course because he
is consumed by the Marvel Zombies the
Marvel Zombies now contain a portion of
the power cosmic really the the whole of
silver surfers power is distributed
among all of them so they are a fraction
as strong as he was but the fact remains
is that they are far stronger than they
were before and they use their abilities
with a power cosmic to really kind of
run rampant throughout the planet Earth
and pretty much destroy virtually all
the other zombies i can assume everybody
they can eventually Galactus shows up
and then they consume Galactus and they
use Galactus as power to spread
throughout the galaxy and with this
final five limited series or I guess
with this this backstory
we don't really know what all takes
place from there there are a series of
one-shots there are a series of three
for issue follow-ups that conclude the
zombies stories but suffice it to say it
is one of these Marvel tales that is
just really fun to read because there's
no political analogies there are no
philosophical allegories it's not as
though zombies represent death and
humanities and ability to escape death
or something like that it's just a
really fun story to read and it's a
really good break away from the monotony
of what can be the preaching nature of a
lot of the Marvel's
to take place today so with that being
said I'm gonna go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it and I will catch you guys later peace